let me bring you some breaking news
reaching us at sky center about this
missing indonesian submarine it uh
disappeared didn't it was last heard of
on wednesday well i can tell you that it
has now been
found apparently broken into at least
three
parts deep in the bali
sea that according to army and navy
officials
the president has sent his condolences
to relatives of the crew we know that 53
crew members
had been in on board now there have been
evidence of debris
at this time yesterday we were telling
you had been found
but residents rescuers we are told now
have found
new objects including a life vest
they belong to those on board this
vessel which lost contact on wednesday
as it prepared
to conduct a torpedo
a drill one naval military chief telling
reporters
in the past few minutes that based on
the evidence it can be stated
that the kri nangala has sunk
and all of its crew those 53 people
on board have died the naval chief
of staff uh somebody else actually has
said the crew
were not to blame for what is being
described as an
accident so just a confirmation then
this missing indonesian submarine which
was last heard of
on wednesday and clearly had run out of
oxygen has now
been found broken into at least three
parts
deep withhold in the sea off bali and
the president
of indonesia has sent his condolences
to relatives of the 53 crew